[Música]
en argentina el invap es una sociedad
del estado que desarrolla energía
atómica y tecnología espacial sus
satélites viajan alrededor del planeta
es el mejor ejemplo quizás que tenemos
de la capacidad que tiene el estado de
innovar
no deberíamos crear un invap de la
educación
imaginen una agencia pública que diseñe
contenidos y estrategias para
transformar el aprendizaje que trabaje
con las escuelas para reescribir lo que
pasa en las aulas que desarrolla
investigación de fronteras para utilizar
por ejemplo la inteligencia artificial
en la educación a gran escala
una agencia con pedagogos diseñadores
científicos de datos artistas filósofos
docentes muchos de ustedes
para que esto sea posible debería estar
blindada de las lógicas políticas de
corto plazo deberían llegar los máximos
especialistas y desarrollar una cultura
una mística de la innovación en la
gestión pública el primer paso es pensar
al estado como posibilidad no como la
variable de todos los ajustes
solo así los cambios en educación no
beneficiarán a los más aventajados
[Aplausos]
[Música]